you said earlier you said I wanted to
make a certain amount of money by age
30. what was your number what was your
target
on the lower end it was seven million
dollars I had built out my spreadsheet
model and assumed a certain rate of
interest and basically said if I make a
certain amount of money this is an
annuity that would be good enough for my
entire life assuming I don't need
Capital to do anything in fact just if
it's time like if I'm writing or
something then if I do something in the
world I have mapped out something like
150 300 million as a
a basis that would get me started on
that path
[Music]
we're officially live so uh Brian I've
been messaging you for like six or eight
months now but basically I'll give like
a very brief background and and you can
kind of like tell us a little bit more
because inevitably I'll miss something
but you've started a bunch of stuff the
most probably the the biggest thing is
Braintree I think you bootstrapped that
right I did so you bootstrap that sold
it for like something like 800 million
dollars to PayPal you guys also bought
venmo which I think is like the greatest
acquisition one of the best Acquisitions
of all time because you bought it for
kind of nothing compared to what it is
now and then you're you've done a bunch
of other things you've done kernel which
is interesting but you and you have this
a fun that's kind of interesting but the
thing that I started reading is your new
thing called blueprint which
the the kind of the I'm kind of an idiot
and so the stupid way of describing it
is like you have your biological age and
then you have your chronological age a
chronological chronological age is just
how many years old you are uh and then
you have your biological which is it
measures a bunch of different things
like your organs your blood and you're
basically trying to reverse your
biological age faster than the
chronological age goes up which
inevitably means you live forever I mean
is that is that basically it and you're
blogging and like sharing everything
along the way is that right great job
what is your chronological age and what
is your current biological age I left my
mother's womb 45 years ago
and
biologically
I'm a few hundred different agents and
so you for example if you're looking at
the age of your heart you can
characterize
the age of the heart from a few dozen
markers you can do the same thing with
other parts of the body so you're
actually a collection of some very large
number of markers because different
parts of the body age at different
speeds and then your life choices and
environment also affects that
so I want to ask you all about this
blueprint thing because I think it's
amazing uh but can I ask you a few
questions about Braintree first please
so Braintree I mean like you know you
guys are owned by PayPal now another uh
another competitor to yours I think is
is stripe which is you know these are
like high-tech companies you know pretty
complicated things how on Earth do you
bootstrap a business like that I mean I
think by like year three or year four
you're doing like eight or nine million
in Revenue I mean you kind of you guys
kind of took off so I understand like
how you were able to bootstrap it
bootstrap it once you got to maybe 10
million in Revenue but how on Earth do
you make something like that from
scratch
I was I guess it started when I was 21.
I decided that I
I wanted to try to do something
meaningful for Humanity I grew up
reading a whole bunch of biographies
about people who had done things their
time and place and I admired
people who tried to identify the thing
on the horizon that was barely reachable
during their lifetimes and they went
after it
and at the age of 21 I didn't know what
that was and I didn't know how I could
do it and so I thought you know give it
my options that I might as well I'll
become an entrepreneur I'll make a whole
bunch of money by the age 30 and then at
that point I'll try to go after
something and so it was a naive
contemplation of how to go about doing
things I'd grown up in a small town like
basically you know with my grandpa on a
farm I didn't meet
um my I didn't meet an engineer until I
was 21 or 22 years old so it was very
much a
a farm boy like uh race in a deeply
religious community and so
I did a bunch of startups and I just
accidentally fell into payments uh
because I
I was building a startup I was
struggling to pay my bills I had a child
at the time and I would do anything for
money I applied for 60 jobs nobody even
contemplate hiring me and so I found
this job to sell credit card processing
services door-to-door and so I agreed to
do it and it was 100 commission and I
became the company's number one
salesperson uh in a matter of months
doing it part time while building my
startup and so I just accidentally
stumbled into payments and learned there
was this big opportunity PayPal had
grown up doing the internet but they had
stopped uh really innovating for a
couple years and so developers didn't
have the tools they liked and so I
started Braintree and we landed a big
deal early on with OpenTable they were
accepting credit cards as a a form of to
increase the likely that the person
would show up for the reservation but
they didn't want to store the critical
data because they had compliance issues
and so we built out a custom solution
for them that allowed us to store
critical data on our side instead of
them so they didn't have the compliance
but still accept credit cards and so
from scratch we built this payment
system uh first for them and we expanded
out to more General merchants and we got
a few customers like Airbnb GitHub Uber
we helped Uber do their uh
hey uh no uh the payment experience
where you get in the car you arrive at
your destination you leave the car no
exchange of payment information no
signing of receipts no printing down
receipts if you start doing a few things
like that and we
um really made our Headway into
high-tech companies going very quickly
they prefer to use our software you just
said a bunch of things that were all
super interesting first of all you're
kind of like Elon Musk without the fame
you're like you had your kind of
payments he had x.com and PayPal you you
had your payments thing now you're doing
like a brain interface and stuff like
that you you do these moonshot projects
trying to live forever that sort of
stuff so I think you're you're fasting
dude you said something about
door-to-door sales and on the Pod we've
talked about this before which is uh
that uh you know our producer who's not
here today because having a baby
um you know he's Mormon and he did his
mission and we talked about you know
what that's like uh we've talked about
you know Cutco and some of these like
you know door-to-door textbook companies
where it really breeds this like amazing
entrepreneur because you have to learn
sales you have to be able to work hard
face rejection all the time you know
that sort of thing and it's like this um
rite of passage I think if you come out
the other side of that you were
successful at daughter of sales I would
bet on you with any role in my company
if you're successful Jordan or sales uh
but I've never done it so I'm just
talking out my ass here is that accurate
in your view and how you know I guess
how do you think about door-to-door
sales and how did you become the number
one when you don't seem like the most uh
you know charismatic you know Science
Guy
I mean I don't know if you had the kind
of the same haircut back then but like I
don't know I don't know
foreign
1917 and 13. and they're currently going
through these important life decisions
on what they study in school and what
they tried to do I'm doing everything I
can to help them focus on CS math and
physics like these are the tools that
you these are the languages you want to
be fluent in to be architects of the
future
and in many ways my choice of doing the
door-to-door sales was just a it was my
hacker attempt at paying the bills with
the child while I buy time before I
start something new and it was out of
desperation it was like I was seeking it
out and so it was just a and that's also
the case just dealing with the reality
of my skills that had grown up and
disarmed like Community deeply religious
didn't have any engineering background
and so the the thing that I enjoyed the
most about the sales was it's not
doing high pressure sales tactics and
it's not trying to
manipulate somebody it's not trying to
perfect the skill it's about getting in
and figuring out this system like what
is really going on and if you
if you jump into the world of payments
in the Year 2007 when I started this
it was defined by Deep distrust
that it was a game where credit card
payments is really expensive and when a
business owner gets their credit card
monthly invoice it's so complicated they
have no idea what's going on and the
providers make it even more complicated
in how they report things and so it
creates this opportunity for people to
be extremely deceptive and create high
commissions and so and look at that
system opportunity number one be honest
be transparent be honest and be
trustworthy and then number two is
because there was so much skepticism on
this businesses didn't know how to
differentiate why should I do this work
with this company versus that company
when in reality most companies were
mostly the same there was it's very hard
to differentiate in payments so two is
making that known so again the customer
has a very clear understanding and then
three is just being reliable and and
competent like that you know that when
the customer interacts with you and your
team they say what an amazing experience
and so it was once you figure out how
the system worked it was very easy to
solve and so I would just walk in and
like the moment you walk into store they
can tell you're not a customer by the
way you're dressed then maybe the way
you're walking whatever and they
immediately hate you
and so you have to overcome this
animosity from the get-go and so I would
take out a hundred dollar bill I'd say I
will I will give you this uh for one
minute of your time and if you say no to
me you can keep it
and I they'd be like all right whatever
this sounds fun what do you got and now
we just walk them through these basic
principles like here's what's going on
here's what they're doing I'm really no
different than anyone else you're just
gonna find something clean and
transparent and reliable with me and
most people be like okay I just I just
want it to be done like I don't want to
deal with any more deception I don't
have to change again I don't want these
machine leases and so it was it was
really just again it's system
uh deconstruction and reconfiguration
and it was the skill set that I tried to
build again and again through every
business I built walking into a a new
world and trying to figure out what is
really going on and then how to
deconstruct it and then maneuver within
it was the early product just like an
agency where you were getting your
friends to help install these credit
card processors or you know what was
that early V1 or Braintree because you
said you're not an engineer what did
that look like because this is pretty
complicated stuff it seems the first
product was for OpenTable it was just
allowing someone to make a reservation
put in their credit card number and have
it stored so to the user it appeared as
if I was entering my credit card
information in the Open Table system
when in fact they're entering it into
our system behind the scenes and so who
built it
I had a team of Engineers of software
Engineers do it and how did you find
that
um I had made enough money from selling
the stuff door-to-door that I could
bootstrap it and hire them how much did
you make roughly did you do it for like
a year or something like that to cover
the bills and all that say create a
stash 11 months and I remember at the 11
month mark my
my portfolio of customers were uh were
generating I think it was like 59 000 a
month
of Revenue
and I thought that's that's interesting
right like I mean I'm coming from this
world where
my family we would decide whether to
spend our five dollar family date Budget
on going through a car wash
or you know going to go and get
something to the restaurant like I we
grew up in so in such a Frugal uh
environment
and then seeing that it was like 59 000
a month now I'd always been wanting to
build I was I was not willing to trade
my time for money you know if someone's
going to say I'll pay you 15 an hour to
do blank I didn't want to make that
exchange I wanted to say I am willing to
take zero
for an indefinite period of time in
exchange the opportunity to make a whole
lot more and that was true like I didn't
make any money until I was really 34
years old I was the entire time was
working for basically zero but uh that's
when I started seeing that what kind of
money you could make in payments on
those residual Revenue basis the 59 000
that was what you were getting as your
residual so that's what the company was
the company was and they were giving me
a cut yeah and so you're getting a cut
of that and So you you're saying these
things where you're like I knew I didn't
want to trade time for money or like I
wanted to like do the biggest like
technological breakthrough and I didn't
know what that was so I first decided to
make some money and buy 30 I'll have
that figured out
um you're saying these things as a 21
year old most people don't know or have
the perspective or wisdom wisdom to to
think that way yeah it's pretty profound
and you're also saying you grew up kind
of like on a small farm in a deeply
religious community so it's not like you
were surrounded by these other like you
know by other technologists or you know
uh you know business sort of like
mentors so where is this coming from did
you three and even this like hundred
dollar bill trick like you know uh did
you read like how do you know Think and
Grow Rich or like what did you do you
read any biographies or books that like
change your way or how the heck did you
do this as a small farm boy to like get
this type of thinking in your brain
yeah I could probably make up an answer
uh it seems to me right now I have no
idea
what
biographies you said you read a lot of
biographies what were you reading that
changed uh your life
and I've probably read over a hundred
maybe even 200 biographies at this point
and uh like for example I would go on
deep Dives of trying to understand
certain world history events like World
War II
and so one entry biography I read is a
gentleman Dietrich Bonhoeffer
he was trying to assassinate Hitler
and so you understand World War II
and he was deeply religious you
understand World War II and Germany and
Nazism through the frame of this
individual and his plans to go about and
his observations about what other people
were doing in the community and so I
found like these these biographies
provided
this back door on how to understand
events as they were told to me in school
in school you have this highly
compressed version of History like all
right everybody let's get on the same
page if we understand these big things
that happened but you really miss out on
the nuance and we all know how flawed
historical accounts are uh because of
just the nature of of humans and the way
people write history and so these
biographies helped me start to piece
together an understanding of reality
that was much more nuanced and sometimes
contrary to to primary narratives and so
it it um it invites me to always reject
the first narrative that's offered
and understand it not for a factual
statement but for
a Wishful attempt to be understood
to be accepted you said earlier you said
I wanted to make a certain amount of
money by age 30. what was your number
what was your target
but on the
on the lower end it was seven million
dollars I had built out my spreadsheet
model and assumed a certain rate of
interest and basically said if I make a
certain amount of money this is an
annuity that will be good enough for my
entire life assuming I don't need
Capital to do anything in fact just if
it's time like I'm writing or something
then if I do something in the world I
have mapped out something like 150 300
million as a
a basis that would get me started on
that path
when you sold when you were 34 right
yes
and what did you uh what were you able
to walk away with were you able to hit
your your your the north end of your
target yeah I hit 300 million what is
that you know you're you're up religious
Farm kid who doesn't know much in and
then in a matter of 11 or 12 years
you're able to walk away with you know
north of 300 million dollars what does
that feel like and what do you do with
that money once it hits your account
you don't seem like a victory dance kind
of guy
wait a second
but true
that's true
it's very true
it's sobering because
you know it's bigger than what you
realize
but you don't know in what ways
and so it wasn't the case that I had a
long list of things I wanted to buy that
were just waiting for this cash to come
in I don't think I've spent any money
for a long time
and I think you're now looking back now
even my
most uh
aggressive expectations on how life
would change weren't even close
to how significantly my reality would
change over the years with that event
well what do you mean what changed
I mean your your relationship with the
world fundamentally changes
I mean uh
in any relationship uh there's power
dynamics of wealth and power and status
and you know age there's all sorts of
things that shape human interactions
and
it creates a different entry point for
everything because now
we all know this from our experiences
when you engage with people of different
powers of different levels it changes
the Dynamics of your relationship with
them expectations interests rationale
justifications
it just Alters everything about I mean I
remember one of the one of the first
stories that I heard
um someone shared with me is is Larry
Bird uh I don't know if it's true the
second or third hand but Larry had a
group of good friends that he went back
to saw and he had just made money I
think signing it for the NBA he sat down
to have dinner with his friends
and Larry was like you know I got it
don't worry about it and his friends are
great great Larry it's amazing thank you
so much second time happens and
everyone's quiet assuming Larry's gonna
pick up the bill he does third time it's
just like of course Larry's gonna pick
this up and probably take it somewhere
else and so Larry from his perspective
just like it
you know the fun was removed because now
instead of me being able to do something
be generous with someone I'm now in this
expectation and so it deterred him from
wanting to interact with people because
there was this expectation on him that
anything he did there would be this
expectation
and so it just it is a um
I think anyone who's experienced fame or
anything of the sort uh there are these
underlying dynamics of human attractions
which are just a reality for everybody
and uh yeah it would have been helpful I
think thinking back uh if I could have
spoken to somebody and if they said hey
like let me just share five really
important things with you on what it
means to have money and how you can best
navigate this because it's taken me some
time to learn
well there's probably going to be like
150 000 people that listen to this you
could be that Mentor for them so what
would you say what are those five things
or give us three at least
one is uh transparency of intent
you know when when you're with somebody
it's very important that you establish
why you're doing what you're doing and
um the roles you're going to play with
each other
if it's ambiguous then it creates
complications in your relationship
and so
um
it's uh it's unpleasant for anyone to be
surprised in a relationship of what
somebody really wants in the
relationship so just transparency like
uh we're doing this on these conditions
um
foreign
money is not a resource that is viable
for necessarily for the things that
allows you to acquire is most valuable
for the time it creates
that you can solve problems
with money
and uh so utilize it wisely not on
acquiring frivolous things
but on solving fundamental problems of
time
and
and then three is um
there's a weird psychological
relationship with it where uh you're not
that
and it is not you
and to have an identity independent of
that
because it can get very confusing if you
don't maintain those clear boundaries
what did you so I know that I read that
you invested 100 million dollars into
your fund which you guys have invested
in all types of cool stuff and it seems
like you've had some really good
outcomes
um and then you started a company called
kernel that we could talk about a little
bit what did you do with the rest did
you this is a good question that Sean
always asks he goes what do you do with
your money you know like if you had a
pie chart like where would it be like
just boring index funds and bonds uh it
was Sean for a long time he was like
heavy into crypto and and having cash
what about you
it depends on what your objectives are I
mean I think
good advice for me at that point would
have been
you are an entrepreneur you're always
going to be an entrepreneur
cash is King like don't put your money
anything that's going to be a liquid uh
so there's been times the past couple
years where I desperately needed cash
and it was not I didn't have liquid
levels that I wanted and so uh liquidity
for entrepreneurs is really important
number two is that um like the the
movement Intel West fund was like okay
wait I did range of venmo
primarily a software engineering
objective within an established industry
of payments I was moving into science
and the question I was trying to solve
for example could we build a global
biological immune system so we all know
that if a problem in the world arises
and that problem can be addressed by
software Engineers coding in their
computers
to solve the problem we're pretty good
at that as a species
if a problem arises in the world
that requires the engineering of biology
of atoms and molecules and organisms
we're not there yet we don't have the
ability to deploy millions of people who
can just engineer biology
at a moment's notice and solve problems
like is the coral reef dying because the
water is too acidic uh we need carbon
capture blank we need you know whatever
the problem is
I wanted to invest in companies that
would basically serve as the
foundational building blocks for
Humanity
of building this infrastructure so we
could actually engineer with the
reliability atoms molecules and
organisms so if I wrote this in this
blog post like if for example a pandemic
happened
it would be amazing if we had these
capabilities to build up the biological
infrastructure of detection vaccine
creation you know remediation whatnot
and that actually that actually was true
uh Ginkgo bio worked one of my first
Investments I ended up working on the
MRNA vaccine
and but it was just this idea of like if
we've done very well mastering
programming bits
we are emerging now powerfully in the
engineering of biology and so some of
the companies like we are doing
synthetic biology engineering one
company is doing they're storing
information on using DNA so instead of a
hard drive made of the material we're
accustomed to they store it on DNA
because that's Nature's hard drive
another company is doing nanotech
building these structures atom by atom
like literally assembling them like
Legos and so the companies and they've
been successful like some of these are
Break Even some of these are are
profitable and so uh I wanted to do this
because
Braintree vendor was was really nice to
teach about software engineering I
wanted to understand
uh science and engineering of science
and so it was really a great educational
experience for me of getting deep in the
trenches with a bunch of PhD
entrepreneurs across the range of all
these different scientific disciplines
how much do you think uh I want to talk
about the health stuff in a second but
how much do you think venmo alone is
worth right now you guys have bought
that for 28 million I think like only
five only like five or six or seven
years into Braintree like pretty early
into braintree's exist and did you pay
mostly cash for that I mean how did you
finance that deal and what do you think
that that's worth now because you keep
saying Braintree venmo as if like venmo
is as powerful or as valuable as
Braintree
I don't know the current value is I mean
I stole the company several years ago I
know it's very valuable and so is
Braintree and so this was a decision I
made when when I did sell range driven
memo for 800 million it was a decision
of okay so I'm now 34 years old
I want to move on to this next stage of
life
uh accumulation of money was not my
objective and I could have stuck with
the company and we could have made more
a bit more valuable
but it was like okay so if I do this
it's 300 million that's a good enough
starting base to go off into these other
things and because they were going to be
in the areas of you know deep Tech I
knew they would take a decade or so to
start it was just going to be a long
startup process and so and looking at
the you know Prime of my ears I thought
I'll take this I'll have a go at this
and try to do something meaningful there
but it was just a calculation of time
and and
reconfiguring my life towards that
and so you've now let's say that's 10
years ago 10 11 years ago
um we're basically 11 years and 100
million dollars in and you probably at
the beginning had a bunch of things that
were bets that you thought were
interesting might pan out predictions
maybe of what what the world might look
like in 2022
um
can you as best as you can give us the
summary of like you know what were you
right about what were you wrong about
and where do you think the uh the big
sort of like
um promise is now
uh the Venture fund has been remarkably
successful especially a as a newbie into
this to this world
uh the number of good Investments
relative to bad Investments is extremely
high so I'd say we've done a remarkably
well on the Deep Tech side with
synthetic biology genomics nanotech on
kernel I think we nailed the technology
selection initially there was the the
idea was could we make brain measurement
ubiquitous Society so we could pretty we
can measure almost everything about
ourselves in a fairly routine way except
for our brains we don't have good
technology explain what Colonel is
people listeners probably don't have a
current list so I mean I've just seen it
as like a helmet that you put on and
like you think something and you could
change like something on a computer
because of your brain waves and so if
you think about uh like so wearables are
a familiar concept we put this thing on
our fingers or our wrists and it gives
us data like uh sleep stats
respiration rate heart rate
cardiovascular expenditure and exercise
like we get these
this set of data and it's pretty easy to
acquire and then we can use this
information to help us understand our
health and wellness
we currently can't do that for our brain
so if I have a question
um
am I in the early stages of cognitive
decline
do I have anxiety if so what kind of
anxiety do I have depression what kind
of depression uh is is my lifestyle
conducive just takes a focus or not what
is my emotional reaction to things and
just really basic questions
and the most people think that their
self-awareness
is basically the center system that
captures their brain like because I'm
conscious and because I can feel when I
have a headache it basically is a robust
enough sensor system
to do it and that's not correct uh so
much happens in our brain that we are
unaware of and there's so much data in
our brain that is informative to what we
want to do
and so this what we at kernel we've done
is we've built a neural Imaging helmet
like you said Sam you just put it on
your head it takes one minute to set up
it uses light
to measure the brain activity and these
creativity patterns are extremely
informative so for example I did I was a
pilot participant for a ketamine study
you know ketamine is has been used for
the treatment of depression we use it as
an off-label study with healthy people
but the question is what does ketamine
do to your brain
and you know you of course someone can
do ketamine they can think hey Sam how
was kind of be like I don't know they
get a different dimension and I think I
feel better but I'm not sure but it's
kind of like you know how was your sleep
for the past week it's an extremely
imprecise answer and you're going on the
subjective self-assessment your memory
space you don't really know and it's
like it's a disaster and so this
this measurement system is basically
meant to standardize the measurement of
the brain and so it the part of the
challenge was building the device of
identifying is there a technology in
existence
that can be built that makes brain
measurement mainstream so everyone does
it for everything
and then second is can we find
applications for early markets and so
we've built the tech we have a few
papers coming out and now we're in the
product Market fit uh finding the first
application for the technology
when you so for the listeners if you
just Google Brian Johnson blueprint
you'll see I don't what's the URL is it
just for the blueprint what is it
blueprint.b Brian johnson.code what uh
sorry time one one final comment on this
just uh for to make this maybe an
attempt to make this intuitive when
people begin experiencing cognitive
decline
and this may be true what happens with
alcohol with intoxication with alcohol
too we just did an alcohol study
when your brain is impaired like we just
always with alcohol uh with moderate
alcohol
your brain uh compensates for the
deficiency and so you you can't pick up
the impairment
but you can you can record it and
identify it but at a certain level of
intoxication your brain can no longer
make up for that impairment and so then
it reveals itself in impairment and
behavior and so that is true with
somebody who may be experiencing coffee
decline you may be along the path of
cognitive decline and you may say I feel
great I seem great I'm moving great
everything's great but you just can't
pick it up and so it's the value of like
oh wouldn't it be amazing if I had the
ability to measure my brain on a routine
basis that informs me of these things
that I myself cannot identify now
wouldn't it be neat if everyone did it
and it was just incorporated into
standard of care across all things and
how we dealt with our Mental Health and
Wellness
you know all the above is is there
anything people can do if they're in
cognitive decline or is it just sort of
like well I've measured this
sad news all right you know well I don't
don't have anything sober up have you
guys ever seen on 23andMe or something
like that that you they used to have
like an all so I guess uh Alzheimer's is
genetic and like there's like a
particular type of Gene that you could
have that increases the likelihood that
you're going to have it in 23andMe used
to do this thing where they said uh all
right you have it but before we can even
tell you if you have it you have to sign
this paperwork saying you're not going
to assume this is a diagnosis and you
can't flip out well I had it and then
like I did flip out and then they
eventually removed that I believe I
don't think they have it anymore because
they said people were just flipping out
too much and one of the reasons They
removed it is they tell you that they
you have this and they're like
good luck like maybe put like frames
like they're like there's all these like
I don't know if they said this but like
people were like if you like have frames
of pictures upside down and so you have
to like work harder to like figure out
who's in the picture that's gonna like
help you like get a stronger brain but
in general when I was researching I was
like oh I have this Gene what I
have to do it people were like uh good
luck you know just like I guess
hopefully you'll be all right but there
wasn't like that many things so yeah
what okay can you actually fix any of
these things
uh we think about it uh all right so
uh we are a customer idea of society
having engineering standards so we know
that when we buy an appliance it's going
to fit through our front door
we don't have to go measure our front
door look at the dimensions of the
website and be like is this going to fit
or not because we know that the door
size is standard the appliance size is
standard it can be moved into my house
that's true for everything we you know
so many things we do in life we just
know these standards when we agree we
build Society so we have millions of
invisible standards
we have very few standards about our
brains because we can't measure it we
know that the timing that's appropriate
for green light red yellow light and red
light on lights because we know the
reaction time of humans to lights we
know breaking power we know people stop
times so we do have data we can actually
determine that we do not have
engineering standards around the brain
depression anxiety problem decline
because we have no measurement and so
the fundamentally the way to
how could we actually
create a step change function change in
the world and how we deal with our minds
you begin with measurement and once you
have numbers science begins with numbers
and counting and then ecosystems form
around that so genetics I think is is
kind of like that it's not as numerical
uh as what the brain measurement could
be but that was a fundamental thing is
if you give everyone the numbers you get
an opportunity to build
um Solutions around those problems
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
so this blueprint your your blog I don't
know what you're calling it your
experiment it's pretty wild because
you know I saw what you used to look
like you weren't bad looking but you
were definitely were thicker than you
are now like your jawline is like crazy
cut right now and like you just look way
different than you used to do I mean
it's pretty fascinating and you know
Braintree is amazing you've built
something amazing this blueprint thing
is like way crazier and unique and odd
and it's awesome and like I've read it
and you're basically if I remember
correctly like I've been following it uh
for a bunch of months and you you do
regular updates and at first um you were
I think you got down to like six percent
body fat and you're like okay I think
six percent is a little bit too low
let's go to seven and a half percent uh
and then you're also like eating this
like nutty pudding I think you called it
uh so you have a vegan diet and you're
like just eating like nuts and like tons
of vitamins and like what appears to be
not tasty boring food like you've gone
all in and the the premise behind this
is I think you had this blog post that
said like late night Brian no longer
gets to make decisions or something like
that like you know you're you're you're
at home at night and you're hungry and
you would go snack and eat bad food and
you're like I'm no longer letting that
guy make any decisions he no longer has
a say we're letting experimental Brian
uh make the decisions from now on
um this thing's crazy man what why are
you doing this and what have you found
to be actually meaningful versus not
meaningful and by the way you're doing
you're doing the knees over toes guy uh
thing I noticed you're like walking
backwards you're doing the tibialis
raises this guy was onto something
you're doing it it looked like I am yeah
I mean so blueprint I had for me uh this
goes back to the age of 21. and to me
this is the best answer I've ever come
up with in my life if you bait if you
pose a question
how can we imagine
the human race and intelligence
generally
surviving itself and thriving
like what is our plan as a species to
thrive
blueprint to me is the best idea I've
ever come come up with and the most
practical idea I've ever come up with to
address that and so from the outside
perspective it appears to be health and
wellness and anti-aging and whatnot
that's all true but really it's a
philosophical Endeavor for the future of
intelligence
and so the way this I would abridge this
is this began in uh from a pro basically
I had a problem of overeating every day
every night at 7 pm I would overeat I'd
rather have a second serving for dinner
or third serving or have desserts or do
something that I would consider to be
self-harm like eating too much food the
wrong food it was just causing bad
things to me I couldn't sleep well it
was I was overweight like all the above
and so I tried everything to fix it and
I couldn't
and so I playfully said I'm going to
fire evening Brian because
the Brian who wakes up in the morning he
exercises he does really well eating
same with lunch Brian at this 5 p.m 10
p.m Brian like boy is he a rascal he's
always making the wrong choice like
I could absolutely rely upon him to make
the wrong choice and he always had an
infinite number of reasons on why today
was okay to do the thing and so I was
like you know what I've had it like he's
done he's absolutely out and so I play
throughout this blog post of like all
Brian's got together we had a discussion
where like Brian even Brian you're
making this thing awful and so I just I
revoked his authority from 5 PM to 10
P.M to eat and so what started off as
like this playful thing now turned into
what I'm trying what I basically have
done to my my entire system is I now
only eat
what my body asks for according to data
and science have you not done that at
all have you had any splurges since
you've started this and do you ever
intend to do that uh I have
had infractions yes although this is I
think this is I think this is the most
interesting part of the entire thing
so um
just to be clear the starting point this
is a big deviation from how Society is
structured right now uh right now
our minds
have unquestioned authority
in deciding what we eat so if you think
about your daily life you go to the
store and you walk down aisles you're
like ah maybe this maybe that
you decide how much you put on your
plate
you decide if you go to a restaurant
you're presented with a menu you decide
if you're going to have a pizza party
you decide if you're going to eat
Doritos like you're making these
decisions all the time
and it's a combination of how you feel
what you want like you know if you're
trying to be good or whatever but you're
basically giving your mind unquestioned
authority to do it
blueprint flips that and it says my mind
has zero Authority
my body has a 100 Authority so it the
measurement of my heart and liver and
lungs and DNA methylation patterns
it directly asks for what it wants via
data
and I can never override it
and so in this idea so the thought
experiment is if you could achieve
perfect health
and maintain perfect health
but it but it required you to accept
basically what an algorithm is doing to
deliver what you eat and when you eat
would you do it
and then in that thought experiment Sam
and I've had this conversation hundreds
of times now
the reaction people have is almost this
fear response
and their conscious mind panics
and it's like I I see it like a computer
screen scrolling of like infinite number
of questions but like what if Cheetos
pizza parties having to play like
whatever and then it like the mind is
panicking for the contemplation of loss
of control
that it can't do the things that it
thinks that the mind says the only way I
can be happy in existence
is if I still get to choose what I do
when I do it and the mind cannot get
over it it cannot just say hold tight
like is it poly let me just
contemplate is it possible
that I am a self-harm machine
I cannot stop myself from committing
self-harm I probably will never be able
to do it and if I keep on doing this
it's probably going to lead to a
predictable outcome
and so it's such an interesting
interaction of rolling through this
thing of and I think it's really on par
if we say like what are the major things
that have impacted Humanity of is the
earth the center of the universe
or you know it did is there an
evolutionary
uh Force creating all things on earth I
think this one could be on that scale of
a societal uh understanding that our
unquestioned
uh granting of authority to our
conscious Minds
is it the root of all of our problems in
society
and so the contemplation here is if I
imagine this
um could I stop self-harm from happening
inside of Brian because just like
there's Wars going on and there's all
these tribal factions the world the same
thing is going inside of me with uh my
own body and my cravings and whatever
else I've achieved goal alignment Within
Myself on this program
and so that's that's really what this
whole thing is about is it's trying to
think through
how could I achieve goal line and we
hear a lot about AI Gold Line with
humans and the acting an existential
threat
that I think the more interesting
starting point is not for me to look on
the other side of my eyeballs and say
let me find everyone else who's got a
problem in the world let me look at
myself and say what is my own internal
chaos in war and can I even try to
resolve conflict Within Myself there's a
there's a part of me that's like wow
this is
um this is incredible I'm going through
the blueprint site of looking at the the
routine of looking at the photo I mean
you're completely shredded this is
amazing
um so there's probably that's like wow
this is incredible and then there's a
part of me that's like you're doing the
thing a little bit where it's like is
this Mayo no he's calling it aioli where
it's like oh wow this is not only just
great for your health this is
Transcendence for the race and the
society and I'm like okay maybe I could
see how that's true but it I mean it
does seem like you're not actually it's
not that your body's deciding your brain
has just decided I'm going to use data
about what my body wants instead of
impulse you know whatever my impulse
driven you know brain was trying to do
before
um but like I guess regardless what I
look at this I'm like this is amazing
but man uh you know this looks like a
full-time pH full-time effort plus PhD
level intelligence uh plus a bunch of
money to be able to do this I think he
says by the way his costs I think say
like three grand a month like it's not
like crazy well I think it's regardless
but it's also like the mental energy
that you would have to put towards doing
this is like you know the real cost so
but but you did it in service of of
other people too so like you know what
is the 80 20 what have you discovered or
been the the highest Leverage
yeah you know changes I know it's in
this but say it out loud because not
everyone's gonna go read the whole thing
so like what are the the highest
leverage changes that you were able to
make
um during this experiment
the first shot on this
um maybe just a reflection
why is it in society
do we
accept
This ferocious system to invite everyone
to commit self-harm
like when you walk into the grocery
store
I mean it is violence
I'll outright violence through the
representation of advertising and
ingredients and sugar
and you're in there and you're supposed
to be on on
equal footing with that like no way
we're outmatched and the same thing when
we're sized up against algorithms
it's a totally unfair match in society
we just gleefully allow this self-harm
and so the individual is pitted against
algorithms and capitalism like good luck
individual
on trying to keep your together
and so it's just it's an unfair thing
and I think it's a uh
it's just bad for everyone to be in this
game but then in terms of like uh the
basics for people
um it's really understanding that
um
trying to win this game with willpower
is a losing game
if you put yourself in a situation where
you have option A and option b you're
probably going to lose 50 of time or
more
and that's the whole thing I've been
trying through a blueprint is yes it's
expensive right now yes like it's
difficult this always happens with
Innovation it's always expensive and
it's inaccessible and then a time it
gets better and that's why I openly blog
about all the things I'm doing is I'm
trying to get this out so others can
improve upon it
the um I think the most important thing
that someone could do to win here would
be to accept the basic principle that
it's a system that drives what you eat
it's not your decision making but but
what about the the like the specific
true are there any like truths or any
like hypotheses that you believe to be
true like for uh you know you're like
well I even though you said you did a
great analogy with the door frame how
it's standard and how bodies aren't
necessarily like that but like has going
vegan like made a huge difference to you
is there anything about like for example
a lot of us sit at chairs you know 80
hours a week uh staring at screens and
we work really hard is there any like
we're like oh you know
he's in a piston squat right now doing
this whole interview yeah
are you like well you know like 30 hours
is I I think in the what's the Israeli
guy he wrote the book Homo sapiens in
one of his books he was like you know
like Hunter and gathers worked only 30
hours a week and that kind of seems like
an ideal number is there anything like
just sapience no homo okay not bad not
bad
I'm inclusive uh so yeah is there any
like is there any truths that that
you've discovered for you that you know
it maybe is not right for everyone else
I started I got my pilot's license
several years ago and
in doing so I was assessing the risk of
death
and one of the stats that uh stood out
to me was that over 70 percent of
incidents in aviation were attributable
to amateur Pilots
and so while I went through the
certification of every plane I flew I
was type rated in every plane and you
know why not
um I refused to fly alone because I knew
the risk of error was just uh the math
was there the stats were there
the same is true with health and
wellness I tried to do this on my own
you know almost like going around this
little bag listening to podcasts reading
books Reading literature and trying to
put Little Gems of insight into my bag
and try to piece together my own
protocol
it's the same as trying to fly an
airplane by myself you know I study it I
get typed in it my error rates just can
be very high
and so
and then three is that um
the value here in this conversation
would not be somebody feeling motivated
in this moment of doing something good
because tomorrow they're going to fail
and it's also the value here is not
debating is a vegan diet better than a
carnivore diet
to me the real essence of this
conversation the only way this
conversation can be of value besides of
all the chatter going around the world
of every no everyone else talking about
this is one is there a engineered
solution that actually solves this from
a system perspective and two uh can you
do so with data
it doesn't do anyone any good to debate
is carnivore better than vegan it's a
meaningless conversation
data is the only thing that matters and
so that's why I publish all my data is
like I mean I'm vegan for ethical and
moral reasons but I'm not vegan uh
because I think it's it's um you know I
didn't at the at layer of abstraction we
just put the data we're agnostic to
these inputs
and so that's really what I'm trying to
say this is not a health and wellness
gig this is not a diet a trend this is
really trying to get the structural
formation of what it means to be human
our relationship with food our
relationship with happiness and and you
know like how we structure our lives and
it's also trying to say let's get past
these silly tribal debates
at these layers of abstraction which are
meaningless and they just confuse
everyone because then people immediately
say first they say eggs are bad for you
then if they're good for you no one
knows and they just stop at that point
when in reality there are more right
answers than wrong in terms of doing
this in a methodical way
you know before we started uh recording
Sean was just like gushing about how
like jacked and ripped you are and how
he thought you looked great is it mostly
uh are you getting any more uh attention
from women or is it all just guys like
Sean who are just like eyeballed you
know
because whenever I have whatever I can
shape I'm like oh yeah my wife's gonna
love this and she's like ah I guess you
look alright uh it's always dudes it's
only men
I I think Sam I would say the
the person most happiest is me
you know like I I had terribly
complicated emotions
looking at myself
in my work years it just was so I felt
so much shame and guilt and lack of
respect because I just felt out of
control
and Powerless
and now when I look at myself
I have such positive emotions
that I'm stable
that things are reliable that I trust
myself you know I trust the systems that
are built is transformed my relationship
with myself it transforms what I think
about what I can become as a person uh
the relationships I have so it's just
it's hard to articulate how significant
of a psychological shift has been for me
and my own understanding
my own identity wow you just gave a
really great answer to a really dope
question uh that was amazing I'm glad
you did that because we set you up with
sort of a goofy question and I think he
said something really profound there
um
I wanted to ask you you said you said
something like there's a bit of a
cliffhanger you were like you know uh
willpower is not the answer you said you
know the the good thing that could come
of this is not oh you listen to this
podcast or and you're motivated to go
you know go eat two pounds of veggies
tomorrow because you know you'll revert
and you're up against this you know the
grocery stores this sugar Casino
basically and then you know you're all
your all your social media is just this
like algorithm designed to hook you and
you know you are sort of yeah David fris
Goliath here uh or I guess bad at algae
Dave one but like you know you were
powerless compared to the the onslaught
that's coming at you try trying to get
you to make a certain decision and
um you know do you but you didn't quite
say you're like you know there's a
system but okay if I take that I'm like
tomorrow I wake up Brian's gone I'm like
got it today is about a system and I'm
gonna be like what the was he
talking about what's the system uh what
am I supposed to do and that's where I
would stop so I want to make sure we
don't leave it at that what would you
say is is the approach that you advocate
for because you say it's the data is it
oh I should begin tracking certain
markers and that's the step to take and
then let my own intuition right is it is
that I gotta Fire evening evening Sean
because I had the same problem I have
the same problem now that you you
described you had then what do you what
would you say is the actionable way
forward that that sort of is the
sustainable successful path yep I'd say
three things uh one
uh fire the worst version of yourself so
whatever you do whatever it is like
whatever time however where the
circumstances are
identify that person
and fire him
so be successful without one act
uh step number two is make a firm
commitment on uh one step towards the
system so for example for me that's
calories I eat
1977 calories per day that's it
not anymore and that is my absolute
budget and I can't go over it and so set
a firm boundary uh that that's what
you're going to do and you're going to
stick with it and then three is you can
start refining the details of what those
calories are and when you eat it you
know you want to pack more nutrition in
over time but just
acknowledge
that you yourself are powerless to win
in a in a moment by moment willpower
game
and structurally set up the path to win
fire the worst version of yourself to
get that
muscle to build it's that very clear
boundaries and then you can you can
refine don't worry about taking on the
whole thing all at once but just this
baby step and then you'll build this
muscle like my 17 year old
is he he does The Identical things I do
and you know Sam you came back you're
like how many times have you made
infractions and like you know so he went
through this whole thing of how many
times did he have to make the error
of eating too much or making an
exception or breaking the protocol or
whatever and it was something like I
don't know I I forget what we talked
about it was like something in the 30s
range you know where I in the morning
he's like Dad I failed like fine fine
right like but he finally got to the
same point what I did where
you can get to that moment and you're
tempted to do something and you can
model out exactly how it's going to fail
to do that thing and you can model out
exactly what it's going to feel like
after you've done that thing you can
model out your sleep and you can model
out your next morning how you feel about
yourself
and pretty soon the simulation becomes
so clear in your mind you're like yeah
no like there's nothing in that series
of events where I win like literally
nowhere why am I going to do it and then
it just becomes a point where it's you
know people ask me like do you have
cheat days and like no like I a cheat
day sounds awful to me it sounds like
the worst feeling in the world to be
full and to be regretful like no I said
last in the world I want to do these
baby steps and you build up your muscles
and then it soon just becomes a way of
being
you uh you're you're clearly incredibly
unique you have you're very insightful
you're very wise you're a person who
like you talk to me and I'm like oh man
this guy has a lot of things figured out
but you're also um you're like very
precise and you're like I follow the
data were you a good manager you think
did people or did people like working
with you and for you or did they find
you to be just like too challenging
because you're so uh
I mean I I joke my team at Braintree but
I didn't care what they thought
I only cared to learn what their
significant others thought
because
it's very hard to get someone's real
opinion of you because it's difficult
for someone to be honest but what we all
know when we go home from work and we're
talking to our significant others like
that's the truth serum in action you
know like where we really say something
and so I do have some data where people
said I'm the best boss they've ever had
in their life I'm sure other people
dislike the way I do certain things but
I certainly
um
I care deeply
about being
a high value person in these people's
lives and so not only you know a good
Steward of the business but a
um
creating an environment where they
become their best elves
was that a learned behavior but was that
like a learned behavior like were you
like well if I treat people right I'm
going to get my outcome and or was it
just like you was this like is this how
you were raised uh like what what
motivated that yeah it just feels like
the right way to do things
I mean like if you think about like more
structurally in society
we accept this Exchange
of spending our life points
for a system of Rewards
that includes status and wealth and
something else and I suppose why I bring
this up is I think
um
we all know how much money is in our
bank account we know how much we weigh
we know how many followers social media
followers we have
but we don't know for example our speed
of Aging like how fast are you Aging in
this moment and if you had aging points
like your bank account would you spend
them a certain way and so what I'm
saying is we have fundamentally accepted
that we are on this decline in life
we're going to spend our life points
we're going to the Grave
and the things that may live on may
include our reputation or like our
contributions or whatever and I'd
suggest now that may be the opportunity
for us to flip it so if you say in the
year 2022 if you're looking at the
Horizon of possibilities for Humanity
like what is the thing you can barely
see which is barely imaginable
you would say
um
basically
don't spend your life points recklessly
if you can live long enough this there
may be a new wave here it's like
blueprint I'm trying to do two things
I'm trying to maximally slow my rate of
Aging because entropy is very strong
you're not going to beat it so I'm right
I'm currently aging at 0.76 so I for
every 365 days a year
I aged 277.
so I basically get like October November
December for free and then for the
months I do age then the progress is to
reverse that aging that has happened so
that I can be the same biological age
and so if we have aging points we have
an agent bank account then Society could
shift instead of us saying we're going
to be a martyr for wealth or status or
whatever
um would it change in that balance and
would it more be about humans so we
become an obsessed about what we can
become the species not what our
technology can become
right and let me ask you you uh like a
lot of people who listen to this are
entrepreneurs and I think one of the
cool things when we have somebody like
you come on versus like you know our
buddy who's doing like a vending machine
Arbitrage and like you know is he tells
a different story which is like oh this
is great I got this income stream coming
in and I was able to quit my job and do
this thing right that's one sort of
inspiring story this is a different one
which is like you know spend your
creative and entrepreneurial energies on
things that really matter both to you
and your lifespan as well as like you
know just the human civilization
um what do you wish people were working
on what opportunities do you see where
you're like man we need more talent and
brains going and trying to solve x or
this breakthrough just happened and
really nobody's doing why or if I had
more time I would be doing it you know
this other thing I'll give you an
example we had Palmer lucky on and we're
like cool you did Oculus now you're
doing Andrew and he was like yeah but
before that I was playing with this idea
of like performing the prison system
this way or creating this like oil-based
food that's like zero calorie food that
would just run straight through you like
he had these like crazy ideas he's like
I think somebody could go do these
things do you have any ideas like that
that are like you know I think somebody
could go do X
I do a lot of them but I would say I'm
really obsessed with one
uh that's uh goal alignment or
cooperation
and at the basis of everything that
exists on planet Earth
there's a singular question at play
cannot cooperate
and so this blueprint thing this
question is can I bring world peace to
Brian
in my body the answer is yes I did
now my mind is is a whole other thing
right the negative self-talk like all
the stuff that goes on in my brain
that's an entirely different project
but blueprint is applicable to climate
change it's the same thing if we were to
measure the world with millions of data
points and let the Earth speak
and then we work within those
constraints
that's the solution for how we can
coexist with a healthy Planet versus
right now our minds overrun the planet
we do what we want when we want and how
we want and it comes at the expense of
our planet so just like we're committing
self-harm to ourselves
we're committing harm to the Earth
collectively it's the same problem
and so if you think about goal alignment
within ourselves between each other with
planet Earth and with AI
it's a gigantic computational goal
alignment problem
and so the idea like this AI alignment
problem we have to talk about now like
between Ai and humans like what like we
don't have goal alignment within
ourselves let alone between humans and
then humans and AI it's a it's kind of a
crazy notion then you know like if you
look at the number of disconnects on
that entire stream and the starting
point in most people's assumptions is
let me start with what I can see and how
I can change other people's behavior
versus looking in and so I'd say yes I
have ideas but none of them matter
Because unless we can solve cooperation
what is it that we have to look forward
to as a species
so what's an example of that so like you
uh you talked about basically like goal
alignment first with your body right and
you were able to solve that and
blueprint is a good example what's
another example of how you would take
this idea of cooperation or goal
alignment and what would be like a more
specific like point of attack or or like
product or service or whatever that
would be created
along those lines I mean the brain like
so I would love to tackle my brain deck
so that's what kernel is if I have this
device and I can measure my brain if you
think about it in like what we eat today
as a dietary input to our bodies you
think about what is my diet for my brain
like the new sources the social media
sources my friends my environment we
have no idea
what's happening we don't we haven't we
haven't measured and so is it possible
that we basically eat 90 junk food in a
given day to our brains because that's
just the way Society is structured and
so I'd love to address that of getting a
baseline of where my brain and then uh
more broadly I've been talking to
several people uh who
uh specialist in math and computational
methodologies to try to figure out are
there mathematical approaches in the
same way that John Nash came up with um
you know a game theory are there
mathematical approaches to think about
how we might solve this uh between
humans between humans and AI between the
human Ai and the planet
and so like you know I can do this with
my body it's a it's a pretty
straightforward thing to do now but it's
just gonna get more complicated uh than
more agents you have in the game so I've
like worked with Tim Ferriss in the past
and like I remember I would ask like we
were just an example is uh he we'd be
walking our dogs together and I'd be
like oh Tim that's a cool dog leash and
he'd be like oh this dog leash you know
the reason it's interesting is made of
horses hair which is good for the dog
for this reason that reason I found it
Japan and uh then we had like biology on
the uh podcast you know and he was like
he would go through these like we would
just ask him like what he had for
breakfast and he would just give us this
like complex answer and it was actually
pretty profound Palmer lucky was kind of
like that too and you are 100 in that
same ballpark where I make a stupid joke
and I ask a dumb question or we ask
something that seems straightforward and
simple and you give like a pretty
profound answer and what's interesting
is you actually do this thing that Elon
does where you ask him a question and
most people don't do this they pause
they don't they'll actually not talk for
like 10 seconds and they just think and
I actually I try not to interrupt
because most people are uncomfortable
with that one time I interrupted you
where I where you got silent by the way
the keto good interviews you don't
interrupt that so I kind of screwed that
up but you uh you like are really
thoughtful and like
in one way it's exhausting because like
everything you say is like profound and
I'm like thinking about it and I'm like
well I want to ask you all these
questions about that too now and this
and this on the other hand it's uh
it's refreshing I mean it's just
enlightening you're just you're you're
just an interesting human and you you
your your intensity is I can see it
being off-putting for some people but
for me like I'm I'm I'm into it uh
you're just a very unique person I think
it's like really interesting to hear uh
your perspective even I don't think
you've said anything that I agree or uh
that I disagree with but maybe you have
and it's like well that's okay but
you're just like an original thinker I
dig it thank you Sam appreciate that
what's uh give us before we go what's
one of these Contraptions behind you uh
give us what is one of these interests
that's just a Keurig machine isn't it
yeah one of them looks like a soda
stream or something
that'd be funny like got me like you
know Coke and Pepsi and yeah is that a
Red Bull yeah
uh yeah so we I last week a couple weeks
ago I we bought a medical grade hospital
grade ultrasound machine
and so part of this has just been buying
a
the kind of equipment that allows us to
do the stuff we're trying to do and so
for example ultrasound so if you look at
the the Pyramid of measurement
wearables are like part of the first
category and then you get to biofluids
like blood draws and and you know urine
and whatever else uh Imaging is an
entirely different quality class and so
if you want to get really good data on
on yourself it's an ultrasound and MRI
and uh you know a lot of stuff we're
doing a kernel and so
um we really had to build up this
infrastructure so one of the reasons why
this is so expensive is we've basically
built out like a mini Clinic hospital
here with all the stuff we have and such
where a lot
and are there like four Dudes just kind
of like that are your Physicians that
monitoring you at all times or what's
going on what's your team what's your
stack for for people with yeah the body
stuff uh for the ultrasound we have five
sonographers so one sonographer
specializes in uh the heart one does
lungs pancreas liver uh kidney another
one does uh musculoskeletal another one
does uh Doppler for the brain and so for
example we just did
um one of the ways to quantify working
out is we're using ultrasound to measure
tendons ligaments like all the component
parts of my joints ankles knees hips
elbows shoulders and then we implement
this these exercise regimes and then we
look at the changes so like are they
working if so what degree so everything
we do is Quantified and so it's not like
oh this thing makes me feel better
feeling to rarely matter with anything
we do and so yeah this the hardware and
the specific team and so just like we
have five sonographers to run the
ultrasound machine we have specialists
in lungs specialists in the heart
specialists in other areas so the team
is like 25 or so maybe now uh all
together that have different specialties
man this is crazy Sean's answer that
question is like I just got like a
poster of dogs playing poker one two
three airpods and a couple empty Diet
Coke cans like we ask you it's like oh
you read that ultrasound actually I
don't need all this measurement like if
you just export my doordash history
it'll tell you yeah
like a greyhound right now yeah does
Chick-fil-A make you older or younger
what are your thoughts on Ranch
dude Brian this has been awesome thanks
for thanks for coming on we've been we
talked about you way back as like this
awesome guy and it's amazing to get to
meet you and hear some of the stories
and ask ask our questions firsthand so
appreciate you coming on yeah thanks for
having me
foreign
[Music]